if you haven't heard of Andrew Tate yet
it's only a matter of time before he
pops up on your news feed his videos
have been viewed over 11 billion times
and in July he was more Google than Kim
Kardashian and Donald Trump he's been
called the king of toxic masculinity he
has said that rape victims should quote
bear responsibility
for being raped uh no that's not what he
said actually he said if you're going to
go out and be a hoe you got to take some
you know a sense of personal
responsibility like oh I'm gonna get so
mad during this oh my God we're getting
earlier this year as part of the rape
and human trafficking investigation that
led to his arrest in 2022 is that true
that you sequestered an American girl
it's not even pretty it's a girl's
average she's ugly I don't have time for
this [ __ ] what about the rape
accusation that's not true at all
foreign
okay cool yeah you just let me know when
when we're allowed
okay yeah yes thank you
prisoner hello hello good to see you
this place is giant yeah I can give you
a quick tour I can't show you a lot of
it a lot of it's like off limits okay
gee come bite them like the way they're
editing it already is this is the normal
level of security you have for your
house every day or is this just for us
this is the normal level security at my
house every day I'm prepared for all
eventualities it's better to be paranoid
I kind of like cars I can tell yeah this
door leads to I can't take you in there
that's classified up on there I can't
take you in there either it's classified
you do know if you go to any off-limit
areas like security you're going to
intercept classified and basically
saying don't make them put a gun in your
face got it TV which I never watch World
title belts this can't be real the way
they're editing are you [ __ ] me it's
painting over here who else lives here
is it just you no I live with my brother
I think you get the best version of
yourself if you live with other
competitive men I I don't have loser
friends I like sitting down with people
and discussing how we can make money
from the conflict in Ukraine that's what
I enjoy I don't want to talk about TV
interesting okay cool hi by the way
sorry to interrupts
editing's crazy shout out Jordan shout
out to Nico the boys are all watching
working working okay this is uh the
woman I'm trying to speak to Georgiana
Nagel would also later be arrested with
Tate in December George on the two
coffees please accused of assisting him
in his human trafficking operation
hey how's it going hi hey how are you
what are these guys up to Conquering the
world my friend that sucks I run
Hustler's University which is now
currently the biggest online educational
platform in the world we've grown
extremely fast we have 110 000 students
inside of a year
for 49 a month Andrew Tate's online
Hustlers University promises to teach
his millions of followers the secrets of
modern wealth creation from crypto
trading to drop shipping no big deal
just the biggest online school in
history is this a sharp sword or is it
kind of a decorative storage
I did a tape speech about why I have
this sword a tate speech is like my
YouTube channel take speech yeah yeah
and I talked about how the number one
problem with the world is that not
enough men walk around their houses with
swords that's up there for sure because
if more men walked on their houses with
swords so many of the world's issues
could be fixed but you have to
extrapolate it okay for example so the
woman panicked she sees something on TV
the man comes home she's like oh you go
we go start wearing the master if the
man walked around with a sword
and she's like put a mask on and be like
I'm brave I don't need a mask I'm a
commander [ __ ] you
symbol of empowerment
you got your sword your wife starts
talking you're like
I decide what I do
be quiet
Andrew's unashamed misogynistic and
violent views so far seemed to match his
YouTube persona
but I'm sorry but anyone with the brain
can see how highly this is edited I
don't want to cut too much I want to
enjoy the documentary but even the way
that they're talking about like the
security the hidden rooms like get out
of here like from a third party if
someone didn't know who Tate was and was
watching this he'd look like a psycho
right you're right they're Stars I'm
already pissed that with they're
starting it with classified they call
I've called him misogynistic already
with you know they're just they're
coming in with an agenda we know that
the agenda here is to make him look
misogynistic oh yeah no this is
absolutely ridiculous to find out how
he's translated those into viral Fame I
accept an invite onto the Tate Brothers
podcast emergency meeting which is also
a chance to get acquainted with his
brother Tristan
and he's going to sing us a song
Andrew's invited his mate on our show
without my consent I'm just gonna have
to bite my tongue and listen to you guys
talk most of this emergency being
otherwise I'm gonna walk off so Matt can
you introduce yourself tell him about
your singing career it's angry no Mom
yes I'm actually not if you watch the
whole stream they're joking and being
super nice with them I don't want to
talk too much like I know people are
here to watch this and we're live but
like this is just pissing me off already
okay no sorry are you calling my brother
a liar you lied to me yes let me ask you
a question
have you ever seen the clown that hides
from gay people oh my God can't be real
have you seen no I haven't yeah so
you've never seen him no is he here
somewhere strange well yeah he's right
here I see him I see him all right let's
be nice to our vice friend so let me be
nice to him before he doesn't hit people
this is definitely a hit piece I've
warned my brother that this is a setup
and this is what everyone I don't care
I'm uninterested I've clearly conquered
the internet I'm clearly Unstoppable I'm
like the board you've invited the
liberal news media to come back
[Music]
I'm violent is that how it is just God
that lies all over the table on the
kickboxing world champion I'm violent if
you are wearing a gun and you have
knives that does make you a little bit
violent no it doesn't no it doesn't
actually security aware
during an outbreak Andrew breaks
character oh dirty second break
[ __ ] another five minutes in a while get
you out of here you couldn't talk you
can talk [ __ ] back you can annoy us if
you want don't worry I know I'm just not
very good I'm not very good at talking
[ __ ]
we've had a long career we have to do um
our normal broadcasting okay
cool man have fun guys yeah bro this is
gonna be the worst documentary about us
what they're gonna say I don't know he
has lots of cars and money all the women
love him
oh no please don't put that on the
internet who cares just as an FYI they
filmed this in August being on their
show okay machine snaps into action
convenient they wait until now wow
already
I hate brothers embarrassed Vice
reporter
's fighting yeah 18
000 likes
246 comments 66 reshares oh I
accidentally liked it
see what people are saying
Tate win as always I'm impressed how
easily he runs over weak men's arguments
posting all these videos so who are all
these people here comes the pyramids hey
brothers embarrassed Vice reporter was
posted by a fan account that has 58
000 followers and 3.9 million likes and
is just posting loads of videos every
single day right in the description of
his account says looking to level up
your life start here it's a sign up link
to the Hustler's University another
account and again a link to the
Hustler's University he's got a clever
formula here
it turns out a big part of Hustler's
University is an affiliate marketing
scheme where boys as young as 13 are
instructed to share controversial videos
of Andrew with links to the hustlers
University underneath if someone signs
up through your link you get 48 of their
subscription fee by financially
incentivizing 110 000 students to share
his content online Andrew has
essentially built an army to make him
rich and famous in a very short space
he's already rich and he's tactically
avoiding the impact of social media
bands because it isn't Andrew himself
posting it's his Legion of fans all I'm
doing is saying and every the [ __ ] that
everyone thinks isn't allowed to say so
that's the reason
I'm starting to wonder whether he's just
a living me you're a loser because your
mentality is loser-ish some kind of
viral marketing campaign to Swindle
money from confused young men
or if he really believes what he says
all I am offering is the truth
[ __ ] I don't know if Hustler's
University is awesome
I I can say for sure that a lot of the
things he says have even like motivated
me oh yeah you know and I see you being
motivated and you know the way you work
out it changed my life I'm gonna be
honest yeah it's changed your life and
not for the worst there's [ __ ] Pizza
Hut ads on right now you guys aren't
missing anything don't worry certainly
not for the worse and I'm a woman and
I'm gaining a positive impact from this
guy that doesn't mean I agree with
everything he says I don't have to I
don't have to agree with everything
anybody says ever to to still like and
enjoy them this is the [ __ ] on the
screen right now I'm watching Buffalo
Wild Wings ads well because they know
it's a bunch of dudes watching it's so
highly edited at least Tristan like
called him out on the [ __ ] they did
they did include the part where he said
he breaks character and he was chill and
he was calm and he was like Hey you know
you can yeah but that just makes him
look worse almost because then it just
makes it seem like he's just playing a
big facade and he doesn't believe
anything he's saying well in a way like
people know he's exaggerating already
that's unfortunate if people hold that
against him because every on-air
personality does that everybody like if
you think that all the news anchors or
the politicians or the actors that
you're seeing are always the way they
are the way they present on television
when you see oh here we go he's back
Andrew first appeared on our screens as
a reality TV star I've never been in a
situation in my life so far am I baby 21
years where I really want something I
didn't get it he had found an arena
where controversial personalities Thrive
I have to manipulate a lot of people to
win but something happened when Andrew
was on Big Brother one of the biggest
reality TV shows of all time this is Big
Brother due to events in the outside
world Andrew has had to leave the Big
Brother house he was reportedly removed
from the program when a video surfaced
to him slapping his ex-girlfriend and
then beating her with a belt I'm sure
they're not going to say that was
consensual
did I say listen did I say listen did I
say it
public outrage simmered down after
Andrew released a video of his ex
claiming it was all part of the
so-called kinky game okay that's just
what we used to do all right but what
the public didn't know and what we can
now reveal is that around the time that
Andrew is playing truth or dare the Big
Brother corpse the UK police had
informed the production company that he
was under investigation for two
incidents involving other women
one of rap and a further of physical
assault
you've talked about 2021 Tate made
reference to his arrest in an appearance
on the fresh and fit podcast
of assault of this dumb hoe
[Music]
during the same period the Tate brothers
were recruiting women for a webcam sex
business
and creating the first of their many
online courses teaching other men how to
do the same
I am per everything it doesn't matter
nowhere else to go it was called the
Tate PhD or pimping hoes degree
when she was doing like my other girls
do I watched this whole course it's
great
closed down the pimping hoes degree to
focus on the Hustler's University I got
my PhD compromised yeah so keep it super
freaking vanilla but with a historic
rape allegation in the UK and the
Romanian police now looking into him for
rape and human trafficking I want to
find out more about his methods of
recruiting women
so we can maybe get one
did you at one point save that the girls
you started as your girlfriends and then
work for the webca industry 100 of the
profit goes to you I think in a lot of
households in the world today the man is
in charge of the Investments I think
that's not an uncommon thing tell me a
view I have that you think is genuinely
insulting or destructive to society I'd
like to hear it you prefer younger women
who are 18 or 19 because you can leave
an imprint on them no when I say being
an imprint I mean that
they're more preferred I understand what
you're trying to say you're trying to
say that like if I get her I can
brainwash her I'm not trying to say that
if you meet a girl who's 22 and you're
her second boyfriend she's probably like
a nicer person less jaded less upset
less suspicious she likes being a
position of power let's not be in a
position of power it's about I enjoy to
show her amazing things you're trying to
attach things to the situation which
aren't true real quick if any of you
guys are interested in learning how to
make money online and my social media
tips make sure to join my Discord I'm
giving out a free preview to everybody
who joined so there's no strings
attached you can get some free sauce
start to network with other people and
if you really want to take your game to
the next level you can join the academy
and learn all my tricks for those of you
guys that don't know before I even got
into social media I generated over 4.5
million dollars in business and when I
left that company I put all my focus
into content creation which is why
you're now seeing my face everywhere
because this is my job so I teach you
guys how to do the same we've had great
reviews so far ton of people can just
get back to the video though don't want
to talk too much peace five years ago
you said rape is a terrible thing but if
you put yourself in a position to be
raped then you should bear some
responsibility for that okay so first we
agree that rape is a terrible thing
point I'm trying to make is the best way
to prevent yourself from being raped is
to have a degree of personal
responsibility and not put yourself in
positions to be raped as opposed to
standing there saying that rape
shouldn't happen because or men raise
our boys better you know what else
shouldn't happen robbery
I want the freedom to walk down the road
with a million dollars in cash is it
fair to compare the desire to walk
around with a million pounds in cash to
someone wanting to just walk around
their own city at night
well female beauty is extremely valuable
Coors female beauty is extremely
valuable in the eyes of men robots
smoked in this game to exploit it
I don't give a [ __ ] about having such a
boot for women I [ __ ] them so they
listen to me so I can get what I
actually want which is not them
it's a means to an end every single Bond
girl was exploited
that's exactly what I do
have you heard the term lover boy before
the Loverboy method bro this dude must
have been in on it bro yourself for the
woman and then making money off of her
in some sort of sex adjacent industry
firstly I would call the webcam industry
far closer to psychology than sex the
webcam industry has prevented more male
suicide than any group of therapists any
action group any charity ever would
right is that true how can you measure
that well it's not about measuring it's
about my personal experience one of the
concerns that people have about that
okay let me let me correct you because
I'm a professional is that it's similar
to or people might consider that a form
of grooming okay so I'm a professional
so I have to confirm I have to change
what you just said I have to at least
con I have to at least challenge you on
it nobody's concerned about anything
that happened 10 years ago when a bunch
of girls got rich there's not a single
female complaining do you think there's
not a secret
have you seen one tell me
Andrew says no woman has complained
about him personally he won't let us
speak to the women who work for him so
for now it's difficult to verify this
claim but I have spoken to many women
who complain about the effect Andrew's
rhetoric is having on their lives
to protect them from harassment I've
agreed not to name them
my ex-boyfriend was radicalized by
educate for the point of threatening to
release revenge porn unless I took back
what I said and on social media against
sexist you know massage in the 60s
the scariest thing is
vulnerable and they're sort of got to go
into the real world carrying those
violent views with them I hope there's
some balance in this documentary
that it's okay to say horrible thing
like women are met in this property and
they get to do what they want with them
it's really disappointed in my
generation
does you represent a new era in modern
misogyny
where you can now not only talk openly
about subjugating and objectifying women
but doing so actually Garners millions
of committed fans
the most hardcore of them have traveled
here to Romania to join the War Room the
war room is a fraternity we're a
Brotherhood which is designed to inspire
the best from our brothers they have to
have the mentality and the pedigree to
survive there's tests and if you do them
you can stay aside
at the top of Andrew's fraternity is a
small group of wealthy and powerful men
who all stand to gain significantly from
the expansion cringe bro oh my God that
inner circle is not happy that I'm here
after our testy exchange this morning
Andrew invites me to watch him train
have you ever bought before no but it
turns out he's planning on teaching me a
lesson
unintentionally walked into a situation
where Andrew Tate is going to train me
how to box hungry
[Music]
I meet and get punched in the face by
the inner circle of the War Room
in the world Andrew is creating not only
are women to be subjugated
sorry that almost felt like I got
knocked out but men defined by their
capacity to inflict violence okay okay
I would we should take this whole thing
and re-narrate it just narrate over it
and make it positive because it can all
be spun positive yeah this is this is
this is horrible this is actually this
is this is trash I'm not even like
trying to be a tate like you know peace
Rider it's just like this is actually
like this is horrible this reminds me of
the um of the pro the 2016 presidential
election when we were watching all these
horrible things about Donald Trump when
I saw them out of you know I saw them in
full context and I saw entire speeches
or entire situations and then I was
watching the news and they were doing
things like this just just
so that's where you know you know it
makes it hard to even wonder if there's
a kernel of truth because this is so
slanted and so obvious what's so I had
some talking points but you know I'm not
the smartest guy I forget [ __ ] I know I
forgot I wish it had a little notepad
the thing that is bothering me the most
is just the fake news aspect of it and
it's not to say that I believe
everything or I believe Andrew Tate is
some sort of Saint or some perfect guy
or we'd be best friends no I don't
necessarily think that but it is so
clear the language the title the
dangerous rise what is dangerous about
those men in the War Room getting in
shape together like I don't know it's
not like he's telling he's getting them
together sitting on like boxing now I've
never seen a documentary like this from
the left about uh antifa who actually
went out and burned cities down no no
you don't see that that is okay that
shit's fine well these guys they're like
they can't even be bothered with regular
people it's not like they're going out
into the world and they're going to
start beating people up they cannot be
bothered they don't give a [ __ ] they
want to just make money have brilliant
ideas execute on them and just keep
building they really that's what really
disturbs this guy the most I think it
would dude I'm being serious I think
this was coordinated because the lover
boy method tell me if I'm wrong in chat
but have any of you heard that to like
the last week and a half the lover boy
[ __ ] that's what the the sex trafficking
thing they're going after him now is the
lover boy stuff it's kind of we like why
else would you wait from August till now
to drop this when he's in jail can't
defend himself and Tristan's band on
Instagram like it's all so coordinated
it's like how can you deny that there's
greater people involved and stringing
this all together the entire airport
industry is built like that they're
making it seem like what he's doing so
bad even when
looking about his affiliate marketing
making him seem like the devil all those
the way they worded it was like pyramid
scheme and it's literally affiliate
marketing it's affiliate marketing if
you get a sale that's it there's no
different layers or nothing there's a
yeah there's no yeah I've been in an MLM
the first course I bought was an MLM I
was in that Forex [ __ ] people make
people make money strictly on affiliate
marketing like shoes Amazon products it
you name it they're making it seem like
it's all like everything he's doing
they're trying very hard to make it seem
Sinister like they're adding Sinister
levels where layers where they don't
even exist that's what's really
disturbing I watched their full stream
with that guy and I didn't I didn't even
know he was a vice documentary dude but
they were joking around with him he was
laughing it was an interesting stream
like it was funny they were all joking
and having a good time so that's why
it's so weird to see this spin in such a
different way right now yeah I don't
know like this is just painful to watch
too another [ __ ] ad that's fine you
know when Tristan said I don't have a
good I warned you that this is just
gonna you know come to bite us or
however he put it and Tate said I don't
care Tate should have cared you don't
you don't invite the the the I allow
manipulation to see where my enemy wants
me to go then I use my mind to break the
Trap and punish the perpetrators the
dopest line ever okay whatever I've made
it into Andrew Tate's war room where 100
of his biggest fans have flown in from
all across the world each paying five
thousand dollars to have their man had
tested by the one they refer to as
Commander none of us know what he has in
store I welcome you all to the test
there is a cage fighting event and every
single one of you has been paired
against a professional fighter you will
fight in the cage on national television
and it's a real fight there are two
paths you can go down you can agree to
fight or you can decide that it's not
for you you have one hour to think and
make a decision
that's going to be a hard no from now
maybe I'll do a yes just to learn a
little bit more of what happens and then
definitely pull out at some point does
anyone have any questions to ask me
there's no training before this fight if
you've been walking through life too
lazy to train is that your problem or my
problem
I couldn't help overhearing some
disagreement within the war to kill
story
what the hell are you doing
it's gonna be fine we have ambulance we
have Medics knocked out don't worry
about it at the center of it all was
Andrew's right-hand man Iggy semi-wise
such a cheat
here I will share with you my secrets
he's the self-proclaimed greatest
hypnotist in the world you will learn
the power of hypnosis and seem to have
an agenda that expanded beyond the war
room itself into something larger and
darker
your sons will marry their daughters
your daughters will marry their sons you
will create legacies enjoying those
juicy steaks that finer Scotch those
smoother cigars he refused to speak to
us but it's clear that he has a big role
to play in whatever the war room's real
agenda is
the War Room
welcome to the test
now is it decision time you are getting
in the cage to fight a professional
fighter who has trained to hurt you
anyone who is fighting please stand up
anyone who is not fighting because they
seated and we will begin the other
program just like that a third of the
room decides to get beaten up for Andrew
take what happens to the people who said
no they're doing something slightly
different describing the reasons they
didn't do it how that affects their life
as a whole whether they're gonna make
any changes in the future to be more
ready for opportunities that's where
honor comes from right from Victory one
of the men who said no agrees to speak
to us as long as we hide his face why
did you say no I have been in the ring
before but just sparring but I was like
professionals and Russians like they
they guys are serious I was just too
scared so then afterwards I felt bad
about myself and I was angry at myself
because it came here to be tested Andrew
Tate has obviously said a lot of kind of
controversial things online what do you
think about that a lot of things are
very controversial but I think the
bottom of his message is a very very
positive one because if I'm not helpful
myself nobody else will be nobody really
cares about me if I don't care about me
right that's what I learned from Andrew
trade people who decided this morning
and people who decided that later date
here we have a chaperone following us
we've been told that we're not allowed
to talk to anyone what about in passing
asking people like what single question
let me run this by tape before we film
no other company okay would you go for
that yeah yeah our chaperone vets who we
speak to and tries to heavily control
our questions
why did you join the war room I don't
want to be certain I need to grow it's
just a fundamental shift in my mindset
what I think could be bad is always good
for the war room I used to being why is
this happening to me now what is this
trying to like teach me about Andrew
Tate specifically and the things he says
online things that get him negative
publicity what do you think about those
things
I think I'm speaking the truth really
yeah
interviewing Under The Chaperone
supervision is proving restrictive yeah
no no Alpha craziness is a bit of an
animal on this one so we can't speak to
anyone okay
who is this mysterious chaperone anyway
hey man hey man how are you good good
how are you
um I was wondering if we could have a
little chat yeah yeah brought over from
Dubai like most warm leaders he has a
sports car do you want to do the
interview in here
oh yeah I don't see why not man and like
most people with a sports car
to show it off
relaxation W Sartorius circles uh
sartorial or the sartorial shooter um
one of the guys who manages
organizational risk and security for the
war and so anyone with any criminal
activity maybe they are showing signs of
being racist or sexist or any of these
sorts of things out straight away we
will not tolerate them and so how do you
reconcile that with some of the things
that Andrew for example says online any
claims of misogyny or the fact that he's
you know spreading hateful words
that's not the reality of who he is and
that's not what the worm stands for
that's not what he stands for there are
many clips of him out there saying I'm
not a misogynist I provide for my women
I would stand up for my women in a
violent situation what do you think his
detractors would say about for example
what you just said the phrase my woman
do you think that they would consider
that to be misogynist the phrase oh my
God for me ties into the very
traditional value
known for it talking a lot about his
multiple girlfriends how does that tie
into this my girlfriend and my boyfriend
my wife men at certain levels can
provide for multiple women and even we
can go back a hundred years ago King's
you know wealthy men they would support
multiple Families how is that a bad
thing it's only very recently that men
and women have been competing in pretty
much in masculine Realms in working
career not that long ago and indeed in
many cultures around the world women
still have the traditional gender norms
and we believe in the war room that's
what leads to happiness rather than a
career or like you have you know your
own agency in the world to pursue your
own goals the women who I know who are
most fulfilled in life
are not trying to do the things that
traditionally men used to do what about
a situation where this is just popped
into my head where I want my girlfriend
who I love to be a capped woman but she
doesn't she wants to pursue a career or
something like that then find a
different woman very simple yeah
the core belief driving the war room and
what men here are seeking is a
misogynist fantasy of a time when they
were Kings and women were subjugated
it's at the heart of what Andrew Tate is
selling
just look at the tweets of Iggy semowise
his second in command
my webcam girl is home 100 of the time
has no time nor interest in going out
she sleeps Cooks cleans does her shows
gives me all the money gets railed by me
and our girlfriends then Smiles thanks
me and goes and does it again tomorrow
welcome to the War Room this is it so
hard for this woke [ __ ] to imagine
that there's a woman that might want
that bro if you ask any of your grandmas
were they going out clubbing doing all
this stuff they're all saying No this is
new this is new where girls are going
out doing this stuff so I don't want to
hear what women women are supposed to be
able to choose their own path but what
if that's a path they want here comes to
Pizza Hut that's not a valid path
because this woke [ __ ] says that that
women can't couldn't want that or women
aren't smart enough to get out of that
if that's not what they want I mean it's
just so ridiculous but a man can be a
woman he'll probably argue all day for a
man to cut off his like the woman's not
smart enough yeah they legit say the
woman's not smart enough to make her own
decisions like there if anything they're
the more sexist ones because they're
saying that women don't have the brain
to take self-accountability and think
for them themselves is insulting to
women because the women in Andrew Tate's
life can can leave they can leave this
is he's not he's not holding them
captive and they're saying okay well
that's what he's being accused of but I
we haven't seen an iota of proof of that
oh the Pizza Hut Marco's Pizza let's go
this is this is painful to watch it is
painful and I and I I just feel sorry
for people that just eat it up you know
that they're sitting there going yeah
he's bad he should be banned just
because he wants a different way of life
you know I I and no do I I want that do
I want to be uh kept Woman by one of
these guys and you know let him just go
and spread his seed everywhere no that
wouldn't have been my choice but I am
okay with other women choosing that if
that's what they want
um
yeah like you can make your own choices
but they're truly happy and you know and
it's healthy for them and it's but they
can at any point get up and end it and
hopefully not have any regrets I do
think well like the sex worker thing
like those girls I think are going to
have regrets regardless but if it wasn't
Andrew Tate that ropes them into that or
talked them into that somebody else
would have I mean if you just watch a
tate interview you can see how
differently he even sounds compared to
this where it's so chopped up oh he
won't let us talk to anybody yeah
because it's a private club and you're
not just you sign an NDA yeah you have
to sign an NDA when you join you're not
even supposed to you know no one's
supposed to know you're in it so it's
like right these people don't want this
camera there it's doing it to not just
to protect himself but to protect the
members from being made to look like
[ __ ] by this very deliberate effort
to make everyone look like a jerk I
still don't see how this is dangerous
like and maybe in my mind is just so far
from the woke left that I can't see how
they're saying that this is that this is
dangerous look at this too look what
someone just pointed this out when you
look up Andrew
nothing nothing comes up well this is
because I have like re report like
previous searches his arrest but I just
did it on a fresh browser and if you
look up Andrew he just like doesn't come
up at all he is a 35 year old influencer
he's been accused of spreading rape
openly condones and celebrates against
women keeping women kids are acting like
the things that he's saying he's such a
joke please stop looking up to Andrew
Tate he is a bad guy
with the pr crisis going on Andrew's
team are eager for some good press so
they send an extra friendly chaperone to
sell me on the benefits of the War Room
experience
I'm alpha wolf okay my role is to be
alpha wolf okay fair enough life is all
about how you deal with the pain and how
you move forward you're going to learn a
lot about yourself as a man so take it
make the best out of it and grow as a
man and be tough all of the men in this
room hate that he said they're eager to
get good press
like how do you know did they say that
to you no because that's how you operate
facts while they come forward to
gratefully take the beatings they've
paid thousands of dollars for it
Andrew Tate's future on social media is
hanging in the balance
and the public backlash is spreading
I'm desperate to ask him about all of
this but first I have to get through
this ridiculous situation that I've
found myself in let's go it's a
self-building experience bro yeah a
challenge
getting the [ __ ] beat out of you would
change you as a man
whatever is going on behind the scenes
watching me get chased around if it's a
smile on Andrew's face
W Andrew let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
what about that wow good for you
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't believe he actually got in there
fine he's fine
those who went all in on their fight
came out badly
your name is knocked out and taken away
on a stretcher
the Inner Circle had put these men
through Collective hardship and
recreated them in Andrew Tate's image
Fighters
he broke his hand on your head if you're
fine so you win I also joined a movement
that was widely accused of normalizing
sexism and rape culture oh my God what
rape culture
out of the crowd what Andrew's team
shame those who refused
don't let it go so anyone who fall you
can put your hand up out of the
experience was was going to change your
life and if you have anything to say to
the people who didn't fight I don't
think I have any word of advice for the
people that didn't do it except that you
should have probably immediately he went
to check on me I'm thinking because I
feel like right so yeah that's what I
want to do right now I have new
mountains to climb
and I'd love to get back here a year
from now and go to the channel of the
guy who beat the [ __ ] out of me didn't
it feel like a movie the last few days I
feel like that's a great metaphor for
Life uh you know we shouldn't be slaves
we shouldn't be working nine-to-five
jobs we should actually make our lives
into I guess a movie
to be known as one of the best fathers
in the war room I can't look at my sons
and tell them to suck it up buttercup
if I don't say yes to this yeah makes
sense
W men W Warren for real all the men here
this is Fight Club to the only real
winner in this performance Andrew Tate
for the people who want to stay and
relax
there's some chicks wow I don't know
where they're from yeah let's have fun I
hope you all enjoyed it
we're told not to film The celebrations
that conclude the evening and it's not
clear exactly what goes on but once
outside the lobby we could clearly see a
room containing naked women being
photographed
bro he's insinuating like they just
raped them like he's just like we got
women don't know where they're from they
just came in a box tonight could be the
last chance to interview him definitely
march to them I hope people see the
[ __ ] in this that some of the things
that you've said which have been viewed
11 billion times
may lead to an attitude towards women
that could be harmful I
am viewership I have perhaps simply
maybe said one thing or maybe two that
has upset a large range of people
wouldn't make sense to just apologize
for some of the things you've said
acknowledge that they have caused harm
and say that you won't say those things
again no and I'll tell you why I'm not
going to apologize for the edits of
other people I'm not going to apologize
for the misunderstandings of other
people there's a whole bunch of Clips
people are making which make me look
very bad that's not good for my life
that's not good for business the clips
that portray your negative light also
help the algorithm to make you become
more famous and more viral I'm not an
expert on algorithms for social media
platforms I do not have most of them
installed if you want to learn social
media algorithms join the get you done
Academy creativity Kit 2.0 shout outs
Nico I'm coming on as a professor real
quick on my phone I cannot control a 15
year old Singaporean decides to do when
he chops me up and calls me names I
can't control that and I wouldn't try to
there has been a lot of bad press about
you that's made some nervousness within
members of the War and why is that well
obviously when people are going to
continue to lie and continue to do very
very shallow very very fictitious
investigations people are going to lose
faith in you the media has lost all
credibility because you do not try and
portray the truth anymore one thing and
that stands in the way of Truth for
example is when we often do
documentaries we have full access to
speak to anyone we want but in this
document we've been very closely watched
by the Sartorius shooter at alpha wolf
picking who we can speak to you know
monitoring the interview what is it that
you're worried that we're going to find
out
this is low it's low we let you in we
tried to take care of you and you sit
here and just attacking us for three
hours bro the world is asking these
questions and the viewers will be asking
these questions it's a consistently any
questions consistent narrative what is
the question about the good he's doing
for men well there's a very clear
narrative I need to leave
in the days afterwards Tate is banned
from YouTube Tick Tock Facebook and
Instagram to the protest of his fans
for a moment this guy is gonna depends
like the guy is making it seem like oh
Facebook and YouTube they all shut them
down because they know best for us it
there's an implication there and what
else has come out since Elon bought
Twitter is all the conspiracies were
true all the conspiracies my Twitter's
finally popping off I couldn't get any
views talking about anything red pill
now my my tweets are going crazy right
now all right you know what nonsense and
this guy this guy is so on the Kool-Aid
that they should be censoring it's
really disgusting that this guy calls
himself a journalist where in a nation
where free the freedom of the press was
I believe the First on Earth for our
press to have that and you know he he's
okay with his own freedoms being cut and
trimmed and smashed he's a bot he's a
[ __ ] boss let's [ __ ] go give me
some
that's [ __ ] lit calm people Bots
but then he reappears on Instagram with
an emoji area this was an affiliate this
wasn't even him
Goofs he moves to Dubai converts to
Islam
sets up a new bank entirely owned by him
smart
and rebrands the Hustler's University as
the real world w real world real world's
fire too
first month after being de-platformed he
made 11 million dollars and got 250
million views on Tick Tock money bad
months later Elon Musk reinstates his
Twitter account and he gains 1 million
followers in 24 hours I have no criminal
charges there's no charges at all
against me I have not hurt any women no
women are coming forward saying Andrew
hit me zero yeah where are these women
they're yet to show them Andrew
maintains that he has never abused a
woman oh but when we get back from
Romania we finally managed to speak to
some women from his past
[Music]
well big thing that upset me a lot was
everyone saying it's a character it's a
character as a character when I know
it's not
to suddenly see him pop up on Tick Tock
just made me really angry
because people don't know what he's done
what are your thoughts I don't think
he's proving any of his points I mean
we'll see what these uh you know
off-camera when he gave me five bottles
of wine that's what one of them said
they were like they said the Tate gave
him five bottles of wine got him drunk
and then he did stuff you know what you
know what's the dumbest part about all
this sex trafficking [ __ ] that's
like saying Bill Gates is going to
McDonald's and robbing them of the
register this dude's Rich he's a
ex-professional fighter he's six foot
four he's like not even on some like
like you know like I love Tate [ __ ] like
it's what girls want a guy with
experience a guy that can like take
control who's dominant why do you think
that he needs to like sex traffic women
it's complete what's interesting is you
know because because I could argue
against you and say you know uh you look
at somebody like um
the guy
Epstein Jeffrey Epstein sex trafficker
and he had all those things he could
have attracted women but he had underage
yeah underage girls so the Forbidden
fruits people have not spent as much
time these same these very same
journalists haven't spent as much time
on Epstein and trying to dig up who was
on that list and demanding to know who
who did that so that they can be brought
to Justice instead they're they're going
after Andrew Tate Haram
I was gonna say something you're right
though what are you going to say I don't
know I forgot I went with you where you
were I mean the the sex trafficking
thing I'm surprised they're still
running with it I mean this whole lover
boy [ __ ] is complete nonsense it is not
is it a crime is it a crime to make
somebody fall in love with you because
if it is there's a you know what half
the world should be in jail because
people manipulate each other all day
long and they lie to their Partners all
day it's going on so give me a break
it's complete [ __ ] and the funny
thing is that if a woman did this to a
guy it wouldn't be sex trafficking so
all their equal rights and all this
equality and complete nonsense wouldn't
apply the other way around if it
happened you know how much girls use
guys it's complete [ __ ] They Don't
Care About Us it's complete nonsense
Amelia began
to Andrew fear of harassment from his
fans she is withholding her real name
there was always things said bad about
him but we're not seeing you again in
2013 I thought oh all these rumors about
it maybe false because she's actually
been really lovely the first time I went
around his house because before it was
like maybe three four times you we got
on dates we started to make out on the
bed wait
out of the blue who wait this this is a
dude saying he made out with teeth no
it's a voice it's a you know a voice
machine they changed it to a male they
named her Amelia or whatever I was zoned
out my bad that's what he was doing
and just laid back said I'm just
contemplating whether I should rape you
or not
promise you within an instant
he changed he just jumped straight on
top of me grabs my throat started
suffocating me strangling me so more I
didn't want to it made him so much more
aggressive to the point where he was
pinning me down hurting me the things he
was saying to me
he was like who do you belong to who do
you belong to and the more I couldn't
see it the more he'd hurt me so I
couldn't see an escape
and I at that point I just gave up I
just gave up
cry and when it stopped
so I'm like
maybe I did what did I want it did I not
I definitely said to him please don't
please don't and he told me shut the
[ __ ] up definitely got strangled
I definitely didn't want it did he think
I wanted it bro if you're going after
that I'm having multiple girlfriends why
would he like so many different accounts
have said such good things about him
with the way he treats people in person
if he has so many other girlfriends why
would he decide to just rape you out of
the blue when he could go next door and
get with his third blonde girlfriend
you're only the second one sweetheart
you're not that special I appreciate
your logic Sonny but you know you do we
you don't know we can sit here and say
you can't be sure that it didn't happen
you can't be sure that it did either so
I don't necessarily I don't necessarily
believe this woman but I don't know what
the hell do I know I wasn't there maybe
she wasn't even there for all we know
but if she was and he was we don't know
so you know you got you got to rein in
your judgment a little bit on that
I don't know Mom when there's so many
other lies like how can you trust this
now I don't trust it but you're saying
don't get don't don't stay so biased but
I'm not gonna get so biased on it and
I'm not gonna get so high and mighty on
this because you know we don't know
truly have you since come to terms with
you didn't ask her did you did you maybe
he will but he didn't ask or did you go
to the police or why you didn't Buck
ahead let's see the notion that that may
not have been consensual that that may
have been unless I thought she wasn't
consensual
but it's hard to use the the word even
though I know technically it's true that
did happen it it that is what happened
to me
I still don't like vocalizing it
am I a bad person
because the more you didn't like it the
more I enjoyed it I [ __ ] loved how
much you hated it turned me on Are you
seriously so offended I strangled you a
little bit you didn't [ __ ] pass out
and all the women I've ever slept with
not a single am I tripping or does this
not even sound like him this sounds like
a deep fake I could be wrong but am I
tripping right now but that like doesn't
it sound like him it sounds a little
like him but you're right one has ever
bitched or complained like you are
bitching and complaining now every few
months Andrew would send me on a
different number message reminds me of
how dangerous he was I thought I'd
remind you of the caliber of man I am I
am one of the most dangerous men on this
planet scan tactics to to make sure I
wouldn't go anywhere go to the police
wouldn't report would always be under
his control it was always to remind me
that he was there
after six months Amelia eventually left
Andrew when she says she began to fear
for her own life six months rape is one
of the look at mom like with how much
they've been trying to cancel him like
them going to rape like that's one of
the things where like the whole public
is gonna get like against Andrew and if
there's no proof like that like it's you
can go after someone put them in jail
with no proof that's one of those things
like he's been saying they're coming
they're gonna come after him for this
and then I know the other people's takes
where it's like oh well if you did these
things he's just covering it up ahead of
time it's like no if you listen to like
him truly talk that's not how yeah let's
get into this though for a second
because all right so she just said so
the first thing was like oh the more you
hated it the more I loved it like that's
Kink that is a choice between two people
that that goes on where it's like you
know that he actually sounded playful in
that like he was leaving her a playful
message and then the next one was like
oh I've never heard someone [ __ ] about
this this much and I was like well that
sounded weird but then they're saying
that they were together for six months
so that message about I've never ever
heard anyone [ __ ] so much as this could
have been about anything facts base mom
W another thing I hate to say it put
this this isn't news that girls like to
like to be dominated this isn't this
isn't that's what I'm saying that's like
a that's a and I'm not saying so what
I'm saying is that there that that
message unless it was time stamped right
after it happened and if she was that
afraid of him she wouldn't have even
said anything to him and if she was that
that afraid of him she's going to stay
for six months but you're right there
this is not news
he also decided to report the incident
to police who logged it yeah
I got phone calls she finally went from
a police officer from harfordshire
police
she said to me
we have two other girls that have come
forward
and said the exact same thing as you
would you please be willing to come onto
this investigation to make this taste
stronger and without any hesitation I
said yes
and I thought well if there's two other
girls I'm not alone now I'm not alone
one of those women was Sally she was 20
when Andrew Tate approached her for
webcam work
due to fears of harassment from his fan
base she is also withholding her real
name
first night that I worked for him and
you bought me like five bottles of wine
drunk because I've never done webcam
work with all due respect five bottles
of wine would put you in the hospital
this is written by the like this is like
the Matrix agents got together and they
wrote this in a room this is insane five
bottles of wine are you kidding me did
no one proofread that before you read
this script my most drunky friends a
girl too a girl too they have half a
bottle and they're [ __ ] half the time
get out of here five bottles of wine is
that like you had a sip of each bottle
what do you I'm very very nervous I
can't believe they included this
we were just sitting on the bed and
Andrew punched me in my arm I went to
the bathroom and cried
um so then when I came out of the
bathroom he was super super nice like
from what I remember and you didn't have
any alcohol at all it was literally just
me that night was having sex and I was
really really drunk that was my first
night did you just see if you drank five
bottles she just said he didn't drink it
was just her when um Andrew was arrested
we were taken in for a proper interview
and it kind of just got left I would
send emails asking them to update I'd
hear nothing back
when we reached out to Hertfordshire
police about this they had this to say
we acknowledged that there were some
delays to the investigation this was
addressed at the time and apologies were
made
the decision to prosecute based on the
police's evidence would be up to the
crown prosecution service
what evidence they turned around and
just said oh they haven't showed any
evidence the whole time am I missing
something do I have like dementia and I
missed like the five bottles of wine
okay two things one there is no evidence
okay if there was if there was evidence
of her if he punched me in the arm look
at my little shoulder first of all he
brought up some push-ups he'd probably
just shatter the bone but let's just say
he went nice on me
Duke you said there would be a big even
if you got strangled that bad there
would be marks around your neck if it
was that bad it was that bad but they're
saying she went months later so now
there's no evidence except for you know
you had a bad experience and maybe
something bad did happen we don't know
we weren't there
um but the other part is that when you
come forth
years or months or weeks after you know
the cops the cops they can they how hard
do you want them to go you want them to
take a guy and on your word go throw
them in a cage you know and and lock and
throw away the key because you you're
months ago they have no evidence they
can't do anything they know they don't
have a case what the hell do you really
want them to do Tristan Tate has the
best take on um on what to do he said
like if if God forbid his daughter got
raped or something happened even if she
doesn't want to go to the police right
away you go to the doctors and you get
evidence you get DNA taken down that way
if you ever do want to go to the police
like why isn't that the stuff that we're
teaching you know like if if you if you
get raped go go at least get proof that
it happened that way it's not just your
word that's like the best advice anybody
could get I don't know if that's I don't
know if that's possible like I don't
know if it's possible to go to the
hospital and have a rape kit done
without why not police I don't get your
baby aborted for like seven dollars all
right let's keep going I'll continue
this case anymore it's just insufficient
evidence you're witnessed
did that not count as evidence for them
no
um they openly said it's really really
difficult to prove right yeah it is cool
that's a crown prosecution service said
in this case we carefully reviewed all
the evidence provided by the police
regarding each complainant and concluded
it did not meet our legal test and there
was no realistic Prospect of a
conviction
only one in a hundred reported rapes
result in a charge let alone a
conviction
okay I'm not even that smart and I'm
poking holes through this documentary
this is ridiculous Tate denied the
assault or rape he said they wanted
money because I fired them the police
understood after the investigation that
I am innocent and the police found
messages from the girls phones where
they were talking between themselves and
planning to lie about me Sally said the
CPS sent a letter saying that one of the
reasons they didn't charge Tate was
because they found voice notes on our
phones where we talked about whether we
should tell the police that he gave us
alcohol we were talking about it because
that is what happened he used to get us
drunk quick note too someone just said
vice took Amber Heard side during her
trial
I don't know if that's totally true but
that wouldn't surprise me with one bit I
didn't really know that anybody took
Amber Heard side because she was a
royalist
saying I love raping you
um I know what I do to you is abusive
and controlling so CPS apparently that's
not enough
bravest thing I think I ever done on my
life
which was hell for he is an absolute
hell those investigation without anyone
knowing and basically to do it alone
with all the waste
despite repeated requests Tate's lawyer
did not provide a response to Amelia's
allegations
and let it run her life conveniently
waited till now navigation into Andrew
Tate and his brother finally led to an
arrest on the 29th of December
The Matrix has attacked me
police accused them of using the
Loverboy method to traffic at least six
women into a romania-based webcam sex
business but we now know similar
allegations have dogged Tate for years
his followers are obsessed with the idea
that the Matrix is conspiring against
him
and the story is the victim of a
conspiracy is it the multi-millionaire
celebrity
or is it the women who claim they were
abandoned by the system
spiciest babies
and stuff and that's so difficult to see
there are bare Role Models out there
don't be fooled by all the money
and the nice cars and all the women
working on yourself and becoming a
better man and better mindset yeah but
real men don't lay their hands on women
of course that's true it's what they
preach too
you also need someone to talk about 100
call them yeah real quick thank you guys
so much for watching um I'm giving a
hundred dollars to someone who who um
joins my Discord server right now I've
been spamming the the chat real quick
another quick shout out stiko thanks for
watching uh the stream creativity hit
2.0 February 1st it's gonna be [ __ ]
sick I'm redoing the whole server
redoing everything I'm coming on as a
the professor
um it's gonna be awesome and shout out
to get [ __ ] done Academy we're doing a
full revamp there a lot of really cool
stuff mom can vouch mom's making a how
to be a gentleman section I have all my
how to make money online social media
tips it's gonna be [ __ ] dope make
sure y'all check it out you're all
positive I'm still mad about this
documentary L documentary for real
though really complete garbage
gone
[Music]
[Music]